sign for roses and roses a hey everybody
I missed the premiere but I'm back I
want to apologize I missed the premiere
of The Bachelorette I was on vacation I
know the timing is terrible
I know but you guys bachelor shows
pretty much run a year round at this
point so I don't have a lot of options
also if I was gonna miss one episode I
feel like the premiere is going to go is
because we kind of learned a lot I
thought these guys in the show already
whatever so true did not disappoint
mm-hmm
let's dive right in am i shiny it's 85
degrees in here I am not exaggerating
just like things are heating up here
they were heating up over on The
Bachelorette
so Rachel Lindsay likes to keep it 100 I
just want to stay true to myself keep it
100
keep it real I'm gonna keep it 100 with
you guys this is $5.00 Rosie it's very
delicious here's a trick I found hold
your Jose up to the light in the store
and if it looks almost clear then find
that it's delicious so on tonight's
episode oh god what happened in the
beginning Oh Ashton Kutcher and Mila
Kunis Joe is our guilty pleasure I love
when big celebrities are fans of The
Bachelorette Ashton calling out that web
oome guy on your court that one here's
the thing about web boom ba boom yeah
boom
whatever it is it's a little OneNote for
me literally
so a shamela have them do this fun
little task in the middle of the field
we love when days are filled and while
boon guy wins yay
nobody was happy about that and Kenny
the wrestler had the best line of the
night about whoa boom guy and Blake
trainer drummer guys drama I'm pro
wrestler I know all about flight do Zack
and crazies ring - Kenny I love it they
apparently share like a roommate
ex-girlfriend and there was an eviction
thing can we get her on the show I want
her to set the record straight as in
this triangle crazy but is the three of
them okay mm-hmm then I'm pretty sure
what happened next
is that Peter got a one-on-one I love
Peter I'm going to say it here I'm going
to set it down on paper I love Peter
he's like a nice calming presence I
wanted to get to know more about him
he's a little bit of a mystery
it's not so webbing in your face so we
had been teased that a girlfriend was
going to show up and I have to say knew
it was going to be Demario because
they'd played him up to be slow
competent it's going to be her and I and
that's exactly what it's going to be and
Oh Lexi an Oscar for Lexi everybody I
mean she was ready for her moment with
catch phrases
he literally still has accused my
apartment with just general phrases I
was a [ __ ] isn't it tomorrow and with
receipts as I actually have from the
messages proof the last thing you came
over and from when you leaving Oh Lexi
well and Rachel did not mess around
she sent Demario packing and if I love
nothing else on this show I love when a
camera person follows a contestant as
they walk away in shame what is reality
TV if not a walk of shame in front of
millions exhibits ABC your way out of
here Demario my
we got a to be continued de mario is
maybe going to return next week so you
guys so far loving this season i think
that rachel is really fun to watch I was
worried there wouldn't be enough drama
this season because Rachel kept telling
me she wanted to keep things drama-free
but oh ho The Bachelor doesn't
disappoint you guys let's finish this
off for Lexi because she's finished
after Mario's career on this show so
cold Kenny and Peter probably my top two
at this point and we're going to kind of
slowly learn more about them also copper
you know Rachel dogs up there you get
more screen time than most of the guys
on this show so you know we're all
trying new things like I have this bang
but I don't know what to do with are you
guys please let me know your thoughts on
this season so far over on Twitter make
sure to like me see on Facebook where we
will be recapping the Bachelorette every
Tuesday morning with a different yes and
subscribe to us on YouTube for rows and
rows a videos will be posted at it's
Tuesday morning as well a lot has in one
Tuesday morning bye
[Music]
you